this was a call to Rally support with
voices of descent growing at home and
abroad President Joe Biden used his
speech in Warsaw to paint the challenge
of the war in Ukraine in Stark terms no
one
no one can turn away their eyes from the
atrocities Russia is committing against
the Ukrainian people it's abhorrent it's
abhorrent
but extraordinarily
as well
has been the response of the Ukrainian
people and the world this unannounced
visit to Kiev the day before perhaps
overshadowed the address but he knows
people are growing tired of the cost of
the pain and of the loss and he
re-emphasized America's commitment to
the battle President Putin's confronto
was something today that you didn't
think was possible a year ago
the Democracy of the world have grown
stronger
not weaker
but the autocrats of the world have
grown weaker not stronger
because in the moments of great upheaval
and uncertainty
that knowing what you stand for is most
important and knowing who stands with
you makes all the difference
the president is aware of those who want
them to do more if he wasn't there was a
sign in a central squid and Warsaw to
remind him calling on America to put
jets in the fight
he won't but aware his Russian
counterparts spoke hours earlier he
addressed the Russian people directly
the United States nations of Europe
do not seek to control or destroy Russia
the West Was Not plotting to attack
Russia as Putin said today
and millions of Russian citizens
who only want to live in peace with
their neighbors are not the enemy
a year ago Joe Biden warned skeptical
allies about the dangers of Russian
troops masked on the border of Ukraine
even as Vladimir Putin was saying he had
no intention of invading this speech was
all about warning those allies of the
consequences of walking away or losing
this fight Alan Fisher Al Jazeera Warsaw